so I've got a rocket here and this
rocket is going to launch a projectile
maybe it's a rock of some kind with the
velocity of 10 meters per second and the
direction of that velocity is going to
be 30 degrees 30 degrees upwards from
the horizontal or the angle between the
direction of the launch and the
horizontal is 30 degrees and what we
want to figure out in this video is how
far does the rock travel we want to
figure out how how far does it travel
does it travel and to simplify this
problem what we're going to do is we're
going to break down this velocity vector
into its vertical and horizontal
components we're going to use a vertical
component so let me just draw it
visually so this velocity vector can be
broken down into its vertical and it is
and its horizontal components and its
horizontal components so we're going to
get some vertical component some amount
of velocity in the upwards direction and
we can figure we can use that to figure
out how long will this rock stay in the
air because it doesn't matter what its
horizontal component is its vertical
component is going to determine how
quickly it decelerates due to gravity
and then re accelerates and essentially
how long it's going to be in the air and
once we figure out how long it's in the
air we can multiply it by we can
multiply it by the horizontal component
of the velocity and that will tell us
how far it travels and once again
the assumption that we're making in this
video is that air resistance is
negligible obviously if there was
significant air resistance this
horizontal velocity would not stay
constant while it's traveling through
the air but we're going to assume that
it does that it does not change that it
is negligible we could assume that we're
doing this experiment on the moon if we
wanted to have a if we want to view it
in pure terms but let's solve the
problem so the first thing we want to do
is we want to break down this velocity
vector we want to break down this
velocity vector that has a magnitude of
10 meters per second and has an angle of
30 degrees with the horizontal we want
to break it down into its X&Y components
or its horizontal and vertical
components so that's it's horizontal
we draw a little bit better that's its
horizontal component and then its
vertical component looks like this this
is its vertical component so let's do
the vertical component first so how do
we figure out the vertical component
given that we know the hypotenuse of
this right triangle and we know this
angle right over here and the angle and
the side this vertical component or the
length of that vertical component or the
magnitude of it is opposite the angle so
we want to figure out the opposite we
have the hypotenuse so once again we
write down so so katoa sine is opposite
over hypotenuse so we know that the sine
the sine of 30 degrees the sine of 30
degrees is going to be equal to the
magnitude of our vertical component so
it's this is the magnitude of velocity
I'll say velocity in the Y direction
that's the vertical direction Y is the
upwards direction is equal to the
magnitude of our velocity of the
velocity in the Y Direction divided by
the magnitude of the hypotenuse or the
magnitude of our original vector divided
by 10 meters per second 10 meters per
second and then to solve for this
quantity right over here we multiply
both sides by 10 and you get 10 sine of
30 10 sine of 30 degrees 10 sine of 30
degrees is going to be equal to the
magnitude of our the magnitude of our
vertical component and so what is the
sine of 30 degrees and this you might
have memorized this from your basic
trigonometry class you could get the
calculator out if you want but sine of
30 degrees is pretty straightforward it
is 1/2 so sine of 30 degrees use a
calculator if you don't remember that or
you remember it now so sine of 30
degrees is 1/2 and so 10 times 1/2 is
going to be 5 so and I forgot the unit's
there so it's 5 meters per second is
equal to the magnitude is equal to the
magnitude of our vertical component
get that in the right color it's equal
to the magnitude of our vertical
component so what does that do what we
this this projectile because it's
vertical component is five meters per
second it will stay in the air the same
amount of time as anything that has a
vertical of a component of five meters
per second if you threw a rock or
projectile straight up with out of at a
velocity five meters per second that
rock or projectile will stay up in the
air as long as this one here because
they have the same vertical component so
let's think about how long it will stay
in the air since we're dealing with the
situation where we're starting at the
ground and we're also finishing at the
same elevation and we're assuming that
air resistance is negligible we can do a
little bit of a simplification here
although I'll do another version where
we do it in the more complicated but I
guess the way that applies to more
situations we could say we could say
well what is our change in velocity here
so if we think about just the vertical
velocity our initial velocity let me
write it this way our initial velocity
and we're talking let me label all of
this so we're talking only in the
vertical let me do all of the vertical
stuff amudha in blue so vertical we're
dealing with the vertical here so our
initial velocity in the vertical
direction our initial velocity in the
vertical direction is going to be five
meters per second it's going to be five
meters per second and we're going to use
the convention that up that up is
positive and that down is negative and
now what is going to be our final
velocity we're going to be going up and
we're going to be decelerated by gravity
we're going to be stationary at some
point and then we're going to start
accelerating back down and if we assume
that air resistance is negligible when
we get back to ground level we will have
the same magnitude of velocity but we'll
be going in the opposite direction so
our final velocity remember we're just
talking about the vertical component
right or right now we haven't even
thought about the horizontal we're just
trying to figure out how long does this
thing stay in the air
so it's final velocity is going to be
negative five negative five meters per
second if this is the initial velocity
the final velocity is going to be
looking like that same magnitude just in
the opposite direction so what's our
change in velocity
in the vertical direction change in
velocity in the vertical direction or in
the Y direction is going to be our final
velocity negative five meters per second
minus our initial velocity minus five
meters per second which is equal to
negative 10 meters per second so how do
we use this information to figure out
how long it's in the air well we know we
know that our vertical our change our
change in our in our vertical velocity
is going to be the same thing or it's
equal to our acceleration in the
vertical Direction times the change in
time times the amount of time that
passes by
what's our acceleration in the vertical
direction well it's the acceleration due
to gravity or the acceleration that
gravity then the force of gravity has on
an object in freefall and so this right
here is going to be negative 9.8 meters
per second squared so this quantity over
here is negative 10 meters per second we
figure that out that's going to be the
change in velocity negative 10 meters
per second is going to be equal to
negative 9.8 negative 9.8 meters per
second squared times our change in time
so to figure out the total amount of
time that we are in the air we just
divide both sides by negative 9.8 meters
per second squared so we get let's just
do that I want to do that in that same
color so I do it in that's not well it's
close enough so we get negative 9.8
meters per second squared negative 9.8
meters per second squared that cancels
out and I get my change in time and I'll
just get the calculator I have a
negative divided by negative so that's a
positive which is good because we want
to go in positive time we assume that
the elapsed time is a positive one and
so what do we get if I get my calculator
out I get my calculator out I have this
is the same thing as positive ten
divided by nine point eight ten divided
by nine point eight gives me one point
zero two I'll just round to two digits
right over there
so that gives me one point zero two
seconds so our change in time so this
right over here is one point zero two so
our change in time delta T well I'm
using lowercase now but I can make this
all lowercase is equal to one point zero
two one point zero two seconds now how
do we use this information to figure out
how far this thing travels well if we
assume that it maintains its horizontal
component of its velocity the whole time
we just assume we can just multiply that
times our change in time and we'll get
the total displacement in the horizontal
direction so to do that we need to
figure out this horizontal component
which we didn't do yet so this is the
component of our velocity in the X
direction or the horizontal direction
once again we break out a little bit of
trigonometry we this this side is
adjacent to the angle so the adjacent
over hypotenuse is the cosine of the
angle cosine of an angle is adjacent
over hypotenuse so we get cosine cosine
of 30 degrees I just want to make sure I
color code it right cosine of 30 degrees
is equal to the adjacent side is equal
to the adjacent side which is the
magnitude of our horizontal component is
equal to the adjacent side over the
hypotenuse over ten meters per second
multiply both sides by 10 meters per
second you get the magnitude of our
adjacent side the color transitioning is
difficult the magnitude of our adjacent
side is equal to 10 meters per second is
equal to 10 meters per second times the
cosine times the cosine of 30 degrees
and you might not remember the cosine of
30 degrees you could use a calculator
for this or you can just if you do
remember it you know that it's the
square root of 3 over 2 square root of 3
over 2 so to figure out the actual
component I'll still have to get a
calculator out if I want and that well I
don't have to use it do it just yet
because I have 10 times the square root
of 3 over 2 which is going to be 10
divided by 2 is 5 so it's going to be
five times the square root of three
meters per second so if I want to figure
out its entice the entire horizontal
displacement so let's think about it
this way
the horizontal displacement that's what
we're trying to figure out the
horizontal displacement s for
displacement is going to be equal to the
average velocity in the in the X
direction or in the horizontal direction
and that's just going to be this five
square roots of three meters per second
because it doesn't change so it's going
to be five I'm going to do that same
color it's going to be the five square
roots of three meters per second times
the change in time times how long it is
in the air and we figure that out it's
one point zero two seconds times one
point zero two seconds the seconds
cancel out with seconds and we'll get an
answer in meters and now we just get our
calculator out to figure it out so we
have five times the square root of three
times one point zero two gives us eight
point eight three meters just around it
so this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to this is going to be
oh sorry this is going to be equal to
eight point eight is that with the
number I got eight point eight three
eight point eight three meters and we're
done
in the next video I'm going to try to
show you another way of solving for this
delta T to show you really that there's
multiple ways to solve this it's a
little bit more complicated but it's
also a little bit more powerful if we
don't start at an end at the same
elevation